thank you very much papa I'm very
pleased to be here and to do this
presentation on I think a topic that
will raise very high on on the Global
Agenda very quickly and I will try to
explain why I believe that that there's
so many potentials when you look at
ecological restoration both from the
economic point of view we're going to
talk a little about but also from the
climate change adaptation point of view
and this work on on ecosystem and the
benefits of restoration of ecosystems
goes has a long history but I think it's
right now when we we have started to get
the tools to actually get things
together and also start to make really
credible calculations because we have a
lot of interesting data a lot of
published data and good data which we
can base our analysis but I got to start
with before we go into your restoration
that mmm to give the perspective on what
type of planet we're living on yeah
there's this new concept of the am
thrown all of you have heard about the
biomes which is a concept to describe
that the typical large scale ecosystems
that covered the surface of the planet
the concept of an throne is trying to
bring in humans as one important actor
influencing ecological processes at all
scales so on this figure you will see an
theorems that are categorized in very
sort of different different types
depending on how dense settlements are
but as you can see you have the red the
purple and the yellow which are all very
much influenced by humans and the green
would be the white Lance these are the
areas in the world that still have less
influence would they will still be
influence but less influence of humans
so you can see that the majority of the
areas on the planet have a very large
human influence where humans would
influence psychological processes at
multiple scales
you can particularly see that Europe
India and Southeast Asia and East Asia
are areas with very high human
settlement a very high impact of humans
on the Florida fauna the microorganisms
and this is the type of new planet that
is emerging that we need to understand
how to deal with how do we deal with a
planet that is becoming increasingly
human dominated I got to show you
another aspect of human domination which
is connectivity each yellow dot here is
an elevated oops
and this shows 24 hours of air traffic
it's morning in East Asia it's not now
it's starting to be morning in Europe
because it when he through wakes is the
whole of Europe becomes yellow all all
airplanes and you will see traffic
starting going from from London and
Paris to New York and other major
American airports I think this in a way
show what's usually very invisible to us
that is the connectivity both within
continents and between continents and
this have major implications both
positive and negative of course that
there are lots of positive that
information sharing and knowledge
sharing but there are also very many
potential dangers of this huge and
increased connectivity that also just
continues so if we look at the planet we
could maybe construct a typology where
we have on the top here brother sort of
wide lands areas with less human impact
but then it's a succession of increasing
human impact all the way down where we
have severely degraded habitats and I
think the policy for a more sustainable
management of ecosystems in the world
will have to be directed how do we stay
away from ending
at the bottom how do we maintain most of
the planet somewhere in between these
two how do we encourage a management of
natural resources that will maintain
essential functions ecological
structures functions and processes to
deliver the ecosystem services on which
human are dependent and we need to put
this in a perspective that we we need to
actually be able to feed another 50%
more people until 2050 and this is a
tremendous challenge and I will explain
why it is a challenge and that is that
for many areas of the world we're
already at the bottom where we have
rather severe degradation of the soil
and I think this map where we see the
red areas being rather severe degraded
areas these are the areas where we
actually need to be very innovative and
think how can we restore this area to be
again productive and contribute to
production of ecosystem services and
particularly food and clean water for a
growing human population on the planet
so this is the great challenge for
restoration ecology to find out how do
we do this in different biomes under
different biological conditions in
different social economic conditions and
other ways which we could actually
develop a template for restoring
ecosystems and particularly also other
very strong economic incentives for
nations for corporations for individuals
to engage in in ecological restoration
when the nations have already decided
that this is a top priority area so this
is the decision from the convention of
biological diversity met in Nagoya and
October last year and one of the targets
target 15 explicitly say that the
nations the 193 nations that are
signatories to the convention agreed
that before 22
at least 15% of all the graded habitats
should be restored and if we go back
that would be 15 percent of these red
areas which is substantial area which
will be needed a lot of input of
knowledge investments economic
incentives and institutions to make this
possible know what is restoration well I
think the most modern definition of
restoration is is a process of assisting
the recovery of an ecosystem that has
been degraded damaged or destroyed so
this is a very pragmatic definition that
you're not including any specific target
that you're restoring to certain
condition that happened to be at that
area hundred years ago or 200 years ago
this pragmatic definition just tells you
that you will assist in the recovery
process from a very low productive State
I think this figure is interesting
showing the different possibilities that
could happen when you start restoring a
system what do you see I'm on a is is
the curve going up to what is called a
reference state and this would be very
unlikely event outcome of a restoration
that you would be so successful that you
will actually 200% reach a target that
will be a very rare event most likely
you will find if you follow a
restoration project something following
the line B maybe this B could be higher
lower on that scale but you will read
some asymptotes and and it will be
difficult for you to to increase the
diversity of ecosystem services or
diversity of species for example over
time that you have to calculate that you
will never perhaps reach a hundred
percent of your target or or your
reference date but there are other
outcomes that we need to keep in mind
and one is
d which actually my interpretation it's
based on empirical data my
interpretation is here that this system
lost resilience that you were very
successful in the beginning but then
there was some perturbation that kicked
the system back and you didn't have
sufficient components and resilience in
that system to maintain it on the
trajectory II I think it's very
troublesome because what we probably
have here is a system that has flipped
so from one stability domain to another
and it's really difficult perhaps
impossible to restore the system that we
have encountered what it's called a
hysteresis effect that in order to flip
the system back you need to invest
enormous lee in reducing those variables
that in the first place
are resulted in in a regime shift that
it's practically or economically
impossible to do and we should be aware
of that e is actually one outcome that
we should count on that we actually will
not be able to restore a system that it
actually has flipped more or less
permanently but in some cases we can
show enormously successful effects of
restoration this is from South Africa
where to the left you see the economic
benefit of a very heavy grazing in a
landscape what they did in South Africa
was that it reduced the grazing the
stalking on cattle in the landscape and
allowed vegetation to come back and you
can see then you have this diversity of
services that emerged from the system
that you have tourism you have carbon
sequestration and carbon storage you
have improved water quality and water
supply and when you add the economic
benefits of those you can see that it
was in fact a very good investment in
this landscape to reduce cattle grazing
not to 0 did they just reduce it
sufficiently enough to get the
vegetation back and to get the
succession going and you got all these
other functions and processes mmm so in
some cases it's very crystal clear that
you could show enormous benefits from
from a restoration management but we
also always have to deal with trade-offs
and I know Tom Barker when he was here
showed the same figure it's out of the
chapter 2 of the d0 it's one way of
capturing these trade-offs which we have
to deal with and understand that on the
x-axis you have a provision ecosystem
service this could be a crops this could
be a fiber or fuel or some other
commodity and on the y-axis we will have
regulating services now there many
different possibilities here that if you
increase the production of a
provisioning service how that would
affect the regulating it could affect it
very steeply like in the first line a
you could have more a linear
relationship or you could have as in see
that the system actually will be very
tolerant that you could increase the
production of provisioning services
quite high before you have a steep
decline which type of relationship you
have in your system is crucial for how
you develop your management but in in
theory you can see that for a for a
given level of production of
provisioning service you could have
three potential levels of regulating
services and the we need to understand
the possibilities moving between them so
if you're down on that level what are
the conditions to moving to the two
others to actually still continue
producing provisioning services but
maintaining a much higher level of
regulating service in your system so
that that you can say what is one
challenge to the restoration that you
don't you don't want to restore by
reducing all the economic provisioning
so the commodities but you want to find
this way how you could maintain
that production and also have a
production regulating services I got to
walk this to because I think this could
also illustrate the way of thinking here
if we take number one here the intensive
agricultural landscape this is a
landscape characterized by by producing
perhaps one of very few provisioning
services and nothing else
very few regulating services this would
be obviously not very sustainable in in
the long run this very intensive
agriculture landscape would be dependent
on on high input of energy pesticides
and fertilizers and given fossil fuel
price increases given climate change and
and water shortages it's very likely
that most of these very intensive
agriculture landscape will move out of
that position the production per hectare
of intensive crops will move to the left
but there are two different alternatives
you can either move along that axis and
it will represent just a reduction or
you can manage the system in when it
transforms so that it also will generate
more regulating services it will be a
better landscape for handling water
regulation for example a better
landscape for soil formation we could
take landscape number two which is more
of a conservation landscape way Society
invested in the protection and
particularly in in tropical areas you
will we will expect increasing pressure
on these areas that they they also have
to generate provisioning services now
there are different ways that could
happen one is just degradation and that
you will use that protected area or that
conservation landscape for some
commodity or there are other
possibilities that you actually could
try to combine the two that you actually
increase the production of provisioning
services while maintaining most of your
regulating services and biodiversity the
number three you have the question
yeah
well yeah this conflict of interest yes
those are very apparent what I think
what the data shows is that this is
probably scale dependent that this type
of relationship you can find on the plot
or maybe on the farm level this type of
relationship is more on on the larger
landscape level so here again the actors
need to go together so this might be
what the the local farmer will
experience but if all the farmers in the
landscape sort of manage their the land
in the same way we might end up over
that tipping point so here's sort of the
regional and national actors also need
to be in a negotiation how do you manage
this larger landscape to avoid that
tipping point and this would relate to
this as well if you go to the degraded
landscape this would be a landscape
there would produce very few
provisioning or non provisioning
services are very few regulating so this
is an area where you have to do
something for it to to generate anything
of value but again they're different
ways that could happen one is that it
just increases the provisioning service
for example you plant biofuel that's it
or you could also restore it by
increasing the diversity of regulating
services and I think the difference
which tractor you will follow would
marry very much depend on the type of
institutions both the national
legislation
economic incentives but also informal
institutions that will be important
locally so in this way I think
restoration ecology is developing into
to science where we actually would talk
about social ecological restoration we
need to look at these two dimensions
simultaneously if it's going to be
effective we need to look at what are
the ecological conditions but we also
need to look at what is social economic
and institutional conditions and what
what are sort of our targets here so I'm
going to walk you through one study that
is right now in review on looking at the
benefits of restoration in the basic
question we asked in this paper what
does it make economic sense to invest in
the restoration of ecosystems we could
find a lot of other arguments why we
should do it mmm if we restore to
increase regulating services if we
restore to increase particularly
aesthetic and cultural services but if
we look at the economics would it make
sense and here I just listed some of the
assumptions that underlie this paper and
an assumptions are critical and you
could choose to sort of use different
types of assumptions and and this is
important that there is a high
transparency on how how did you do your
calculations and what were your
assumptions in this case we used the
20-year horizon which is bounded
timeframe we were looking at we were
looking at discount rates from -2 to up
to 8% and the high discount rate in this
case is adding more way to the cost than
to the benefits we also introduced an
operating cost in the maintenance of
auto restoration and then we looked at
the benefits that they were not
immediately apparent from year 1 that
there was this phasing in of benefits
because
there is a succession going on in the
system with increasing complexity and
functions and processes so very likely
you would have a time lag before you
could actually cash in the benefits mmm
of your restoration effort this this of
course would vary very much from one
system to another
here we use some sort of an average for
a large number of different systems but
ideally you would like to fine-tune them
to each specific system but this and
this study now started to scrutinize
some 2000 papers on restoration and came
down to about 200 that actually had
information on the benefits and the cost
of restoration and so here is
compilation of the benefits and what you
can see in this table a lot of figures
but what I think actually sticks out the
most is that our benefits from coral
reefs and coastal systems are very high
so in the order of 6 million dollars per
hectare or two and a half to six million
dollars per hectare for coral reefs
but then we were also looking at the
cost of restoration and this I think is
the first time there's really be made a
very comprehensive assessment of the
cost of restoration so about 200 studies
have been included in this analysis and
what this shows is that we have a
variation in cost of restoration and
even though benefits of coral reefs are
high so are the cost of restoration one
for some summer there's like grasslands
the cost of restoration is quite low so
the next step then is actually to look
at the benefit cost ratios this is the
interesting graph to look at what is
actually are the benefit given the
investment you have to do and as you see
coral reefs that call benefit cost ratio
is quite low it's still positive it
still they still generate benefits but
both high cost and high high benefits
and but then we move through these
biomes so when we come to tropical
forest temperate forests we're getting
into quite high benefit cost ratios and
and for grasslands it could be
particularly high it's interesting for
example they look at tropical forests
that the benefit cost ratio there that
it could be very high and when you look
back you can see that the cost could
actually be very low in some tropical
areas and again this is scale dependent
if you have restoration of a tropical
forest where you have lots of genetic
sources seeds and dispersing animals
this is a succession that will cost very
little and you will get quite rapidly
growing forests with very high
complexity you had a question
yeah but you as you see the ranges are
quite big so yes you mean the cost would
be different from one region to another
and the benefits as well yeah so but
this is sort of transferred into the
2007 sort of costing in US dollars but
there's some sort of transfer mechanism
here too to get the comparability so the
conclusions from this paper going
through several thousands of paper
ending up with a couple of hundred that
have really good data is that we're
starting to get more and more confident
about what are the benefits cost ratios
of restoration and and that it could
range and be quite low so for example
for coral reefs around one but up tiers
high as 27 for grasslands so particular
grasslands would generally generate high
benefits and then of course we need to
take encountered in these studies not
all services were calculated an economic
benefit and also there are of course
services whether they're it's difficult
to calculate or perhaps we shouldn't
calculate economic benefit with all the
services that are related to cultural
the cultural dimension and so services
are related to religion aesthetics and
so forth and these also need to be in
one way or another taking into account
that when you're restoring a system
you're also in the process assisting in
restoring some of those services which
are not possible to put an economic
value
now I got a switch talking about more
specifically on restoration in urban
landscapes and the reason I doing that
is because well are two reasons one is
that when you go to a very highly
populated urban area you have a huge
number of beneficiaries oh just a very
tiny investment just restoring one
hectare could serve thousands or tens of
thousands of people so there is this
potential of having a very large
outreach of even a small investment the
other one is well actually the three
reasons are bring this up with the other
one is that we are getting more and more
studies showing that green spaces in
cities are very important for for human
health and that having green spaces will
reduce health expenditure quite
substantially so it's interesting for
municipalities to start calculating that
avoided cost by having green spaces in
cities that are used for recreation and
the third which our country is that
cities are facing a particular
challenges when it comes to climate
change and we're actually ecosystems
could be I would argue a low cost low
maintenance and low-carbon option for
dealing with those challenges but the
world goes to town in 2030 we're going
to be 5 billion people living in cities
nearly a doubling from today and someone
said that human history will evermore
become urban history we're becoming an
urban species and we need to learn more
about this urban habitat this is just a
reflection of how rapid this processes
in 1950 there were eight cities are in
the world that were mega cities more
than five million people in 2015 just
four years from now they've got to be 80
and most of them in in East Asia this is
an enormous incredibly rapid development
and
we also have a huge knowledge gap the
millennium ecosystem assessment made a
huge and I think tremendous effort in in
bringing forth understanding of
ecosystems and ecosystem services all
around the world except the urban there
is this tiny chapter in all of the MA
20 volumes that deals with with urban
system and then when you go to the world
development report published by the
World Bank which is probably the largest
assessment of urbanization it deals with
demography sanitation health issues but
rarely mentions ecosystems so here's a
gap we need to bridge and try to
understand what what understanding do we
have a weak systems and what are their
roles in in the urban context and there
are ecosystem services in urban areas
and but they are poorly understood and
poorly investigated and we don't have
really good valuation of these ecosystem
services here is one way of building a
topology of these ecosystem services and
so to the left you would have mostly
these regulating services that could be
important for climate change adaptation
to regulate water we have the the more
biological related services and to the
right I think what is even more
emphasized in in the urban area is the
cultural dimension of ecosystems and
their connection to health issues which
really needs to be brought on the table
and understood so what did we deal with
urban degraded land there are lots of
urban degraded land and could we
actually restore these to functioning
systems and what would be the value of
the services they would generate this
picture is taken not very far from here
this is Fresh Kills landfill in on
Staten Island in New York this was a
landfill that was closed in in the 90s
and the city decided that after the
closing that they would actually invest
money substantial money in restoring
this to become an amenity
area for recreation that was a very bold
decision given the way it looked and
given that you have probably the most
severe conditions for restoration you
had toxic soils you have lots of plastic
and non biological material you had very
species poor vegetation to start with
you are all sorts of problems to deal
with so this was a challenge for for the
ecologist that started and I want to
give a tribute to you as professor
Stephen handle at Rutgers University
that led the biological part of this he
made a tremendous effort in him actually
showing how you could do this how you
could go from this and you look down
there to the left this is what it looks
today and here is sort of the more
visionary for the future hopefully much
taller that will be be realized but what
I did was that they brought in soil this
was absolutely necessary because you had
so much toxins on that landfill so they
put out a rubber sheet to protect the
groundwater and then then they put more
than a meter of new soil on top of that
and that was solid in new soil they used
for planting vegetation and this is the
tricky thing with the restoration in
urban areas that usually you you were
dealing with very poor soils and often
toxic soils so the most costly part of
the restoration would actually be this
initial trying to deal with with
increasing the soil quality but then
they did I think something really
interesting and clever in and it worked
beautifully and daddy that was that they
actually did plant little islands of
trees that produce fleshy fruits mmm in
that big area and what happened was that
they started to attract birds from
nearby remnant forest and what what they
actually
to create was sort of a natural
successional process that birds would
fly in they will carry seeds and they
would drop the seeds and you will start
succession and even in the first year
mmm they got about 25 different species
of trees and shrubs that previous fleshy
fruits that actually ended up in there
see trap state where they were
monitoring and here's just a list what
they got and then the second year that
got even more but different species so
over time they had a huge diversity of
species moving into this area and this
graph shows that these islands they
created out in this huge restoration
area was crucial for that attracting
these birds and the birds who drop the
seeds and you would get these seedlings
growing up in these islands and those
islands would then be sort of hotspots
and from there the succession would take
arm so even though costs were really
high for managing the soil in the
beginning this was very cheap because we
used they used all the birds to bring in
a native flora into this area and this
is what it looks like today and what you
can see around this area now is that the
property rights start to increase and
that is actually part of financing the
restoration that the revenues from
increasing or the property values are
increasing so the tax will be used for
for paying some of the restoration and I
think there was some important lessons
from this project that you could get
significant and rather rapid effects on
many consistent services in this area
even though the conditions were really
bad when you started and that in an
urban area you have these other
possibilities of finding sources of
finance like when property rights values
go up that the taxes would be part of
contributing to financing but yeah I
think it started in 98 then uh when 9/11
happened they open up Fresh Kills again
to take all the debris from from
Manhattan from the two towers and then
after that and they there was a long
discussion on the future of this because
them there was many that raised the
voice that we want to make this a
Memorial Park and so now they sort of
changed the design now it's got to be
very nicely a Memorial Park but there
were lots of strong feelings at the time
because a lot of people said it they
objected that the relatives will be end
up on a landfill and but I think now
they there is a consensus that this will
be a very nice memorial place in
commemoration while a lot of the people
that died in 9/11 but what hasn't been
done really for The Fresh Kills area is
to look at sort of the aggregated
benefits of that restoration and we went
through this is another paper that was
sent in simultaneously with the other
one just just right a few days ago
looking at the benefits of ecosystem
services restoration of ecosystem
services and cities and here we didn't
we couldn't start with 2000 papers we
found Tim that's it I mean it's I I was
there must be more research there were
only 10 papers which had actually dealt
with benefits and looking at and also
cost and made those calculations on on
an area basis and were yeah
so here is an area for doing a lot of
exciting research in the future
what we found was that the studies have
made quantification ecosystem services
so they've been looking at pollution
control carbon storage stormwater
reduction energy savings and you see the
mostly North American and Chinese cities
so far we found it few in South Africa
and one in Canada but still the lots
large parts of the world where where we
need to understand these things much
better so based on these calculations in
quantifications of all these services
these papers so these authors have had
also transferred them into an economic
value so here we have estimates of
economic value and this would be the
generation of benefits per hectare per
year and for thirteen different services
and again air quality carbon
sequestration storage recreation
positive health effects
there was only one study that actually
did an per area basis calculation of
health effects but it's very high but
since there's only one study we did not
include it and in our average we ended
up with an M with an average of of
12,000 US dollar per hectare per year
and and with a range between 5 to 20,000
US dollar per hectare per year yeah
yes yes mmm
they're lucky I mean there are lots of
studies they've done estimates of health
effects but not on a per hectare base
yeah yeah and then we looked after
literature on the cost of restoration
and again we didn't have 2,000 studies
to start with just a handful that
actually provided a cost of restoration
so so these are the average they're
quite high numbers but this is what you
expect in urban areas particularly when
when you have to deal with poor soil
conditions but again then we looked at
the benefit cost ratios and we put the
urban like in in that if again an
interesting it had it sort of ends up
here in the right part of the figure you
have a range from about 2 to 15 but it's
comparable to the benefit cost ratios
for forest or woodlands in more rural
areas and again this will not take into
account the cultural values of these and
we have not taken into account the
health value so if we do the health
value this might just spike right up so
the benefit the conclusions here that we
have a range from 2 to 5 given all these
constraints of this study which is
comparable to restoration elsewhere I
mean
restoration in an urban area given the
complexities and the high cost is still
has a range that is substantial and this
should actually be on the table in in
the urban planning that when you're
deciding what to do if you have
industrial area brownfield area
which you're planning to develop that
that could be different options that
your of course you build new housing and
you build malls and you build
infrastructure but this could also be
part of that planning and and actually
taking encounter benefits of that
restoration and given that it could
actually be much much higher than we
have indicated here and also one thing
we didn't take into account is sort of
the value these ecosystems could have in
the urban landscape when it comes to
climate change this is what all cities
have to face how to adapt to climate
change and also the transformation to a
future beyond fossil fuels these are
major major challenges and I argue that
the lots of opportunities for innovative
use and restoration of ecosystems to
address this this could be for example
addressing the heat island effect heat
waves flooding storm mmm food production
I will not talk too much about that
today but that's a whole other area of
urban agriculture and lastly someone's
carbon sequestration but urban heat
waves is becoming a great concern and in
Europe we have in 2003 a very severe
heat wave that caused an excess
mortality of about 70,000 in the cities
and the two segments of the population
are particularly vulnerable one is the
older segment that perhaps is less
mobile and and get dehydrated and the
youngest which is also less mobile and
get dehydrate and so among these two
groups we have a very high excess
mortality and this is something that
society needs to take into account when
planning for for the future that we will
have heat waves and it will affect the
population and and what can we do about
it so
for example for Greater Manchester they
calculated these areas which will show
really high peaks in temperature during
heat waves given different scenarios so
climate change and what could you then
do about it well one is to plant trees
it's very simple there is a very strong
cooling effect of trees and if you
increase the canopy cover 10% from 10 to
20 in a city you might reduce the
ambient temperature of 3 3 degrees which
is a substantial decrease when it comes
to reducing those Peaks in a lot of
cities in Europe in North America now I
have put this 20% as one of the targets
and in New York there is a 1 million
tree project in Los Angeles at 2 million
3 projects and but they all have there
are several reasons why they've started
this but one is is to actually
accomplish this cooling effect and and
that's why they also tend to plant them
in areas which have already very little
green so they would increase the amount
of green and in Manchester they did this
calculation where they actually compared
given this different scenarios for
climate change and temperature increase
where they had a scenario also with
losing 10% of the green spaces or adding
10% but like restoring compared to
status quo and and what you can see to
the right here in 2018 on the high
scenario that the difference between
restoring 10 percent increasing 10
percent of green area and losing is
about 8 degrees which is a substantial
change or substantial difference in in
climate in the city
here's another example of where
large-scale restoration is becoming high
on the agenda this is a familiar picture
this huge trauma in September 2005 in
New Orleans but what is happening in
southern Louisiana and maybe there are
people here from from New Orleans or
southern Louisiana but this realization
that they're huge wetlands in Cinelli
Louisiana that disappeared the last 50
60 years and actually made New Orleans
much much more vulnerable to the storm
so what is happening now is is
investment in restoration of wetlands
it's a slow process and it's very
expensive but again the benefits of that
are huge if you could because this is
New Orleans with two or three hundred
thousand people preparing for future
with climate change not only would
increase frequency hurricanes but also
rising sea level and we know that every
kilometer of wetland and would reduce
the wave height by one meter so you
could actually transfer that into how
you build safety for the city so I think
this gives a lot of impetus to dig
deeper into how restoration actually
could be used as part of the strategy to
meet climate change challenges and in I
think particularly in cities one of the
most important and to reduce the risk of
natural hazards but also secure water
energy and food security as written here
on this table that outline one of the
projects you doing so I think it would
be really fantastic if someone you would
engage in and investigating this further
and much more in detail and this is
quite a new area and and also I think
it's hard because there's not much
written about it but also exciting
because if you do write something you
would be one of refers to put
there's some on a paper or starting a
discussion about this so I think it's
very worthwhile doing it particularly
instance as you've seen the huge amount
of money in in these funds for climate
change adaptation but usually are from
these foundations they are not thinking
of that thick that they should be
challenging to restoration but if we
could provide and show the links that if
you do this investment in restoration it
will generate this benefit and this
capacity to to address climate change
challenges so I will end there with this
question to what extent these funds
could actually be used for restoration
to reduce risk and vulnerability and
build resilience to climate change I
think it's a very important questions
and it needs to be addressed and
answered so thank you very much